mama don't like you and she likes
everyone cuz you're a [ __ ] hey what is
going on YouTube now recently a
subscriber asked David I think my
girlfriend is a little bit unreasonable
I buy her things I always pay for her
meals I opened the door for her but she
says that's not enough and all she wants
me to do is spend quality time with her
I think that I do what the hell is her
problem now not surprising to people
this is the dilemma that a lot of people
have in their relationships one person
says I am loving you because I'm doing
this for you but the other person says
now I want you to take this advice with
a grain of salt because I'm only saying
this to you because I was once yeah I
speak that too I used to think that with
the girl that I am with this is what I'm
doing for you why can't you just see the
positives all you see is the negatives
all you see is that is a hat is a glass
filled with half pissed that's not the
same somebody glass and when you filled
it up and he's supposed to be happy
oh somebody so before I tell this to you
take this very lightly it's not that
serious but you are stupid as [ __ ] all
[ __ ] David call him stupid he's signing
with girls and not the guys oh no no
that's not it I'm not trying to believe
it the captain save-a-ho that's
Vietnamese captain save-a-ho for those
people who didn't understand get been
psycho but you said something very
stupid and naive you are asking the
person that you're with to be loved the
way that you want to be loved
oh [ __ ] mic drop I'm not wearing pants
like you cannot expect them to be loved
the way that you want to see for you you
equate affection and love by gifts is
what I call it when somebody gives you a
gift that's worthwhile or something that
you like or that you wanted you feel
loved do you feel like that person cares
about you that person thought about you
headband
I got you a pair of sunglasses because
you always wanted it do you know
you are the best girlfriend on earth am
I gonna get a [ __ ] later - no and see
that's perfectly fine I'm not saying
that you wanting gifts is a wrong thing
but what I am saying is that that's not
what she wants I don't know what her
love language is but obviously it's not
in the form of gifts so you can't keep
shoving that in her face and expect to
appreciate something that she doesn't
really give two [ __ ] about so no matter
what you get hurt besides probably a
million dollars and for those guys or
girls out there that still don't get
this concept that you just equated as
I'm still doing something so be
appreciative let me tell you this if you
want it to be that way
just just go [ __ ] yourself then if you
want to be with somebody just like you
go [ __ ] yourself whoo baby you can go
and [ __ ] yourself my mama don't like you
and she likes everyone cuz you were B
there's no other reason how could your
mom like everybody else but you yeah
[ __ ] so your [ __ ] smell like fish
sauce I don't if you still don't
understand us let me just give you an
example of how this works in a different
type of relationship remember when you
were a kid and then Christmas came
around you were super excited you
already knew what type of toy that you
wanted and you know during Christmas
time mom and dad was gonna get you what
you wanted because you've been telling
them that this is it and then when
christmas came by you came down your
stupid little [ __ ] stairs opened up
your present and what did you find a
[ __ ] sweater and you cried and then
you look at your parents then you told
your parents what the [ __ ] is this I
told you I wanted a game and what did
your parents say to you you ungrateful
little fat Korean [ __ ] this is a gift
and you should love it based on the fact
that I gave you something special
Oh does that sound familiar who does
that sound like my drop and a better
analogy is this it's like giving a gift
to someone on their birthday and when
they opened up the gift it was something
that they hated but you love what a
[ __ ] shitty gift is that so if you
want to treat your friends like that in
your friendships why would you treat
your girlfriend like that in your
relationship and trust me dude if you
love the person the way that they want
to be loved and you guys connect
a certain level and you know you don't
have to beg for the blue you know all
those times that she's mad at you even
though you've given her gifts and that's
not what she wanted she just wanted you
to cuddle her and you wouldn't do that
so at night you had to do this be
open-minded have an open heart and
learned to love somebody in their love
language and watch how your
relationships flourish with my last
relationship I didn't do that at all and
guess what happened she's stuck here I
traded in like a pawn shop that blow job
for the sunglasses no okay hey what is
going on YouTube now remember every
video will be up Sundays at 12 p.m. if
you guys want to see more topics that's
really up to you you just kind of leave
those in the comments below people
thumbs up and like the comments or the
topics that you guys want to hear about
and I am here for you
I'm here to talk to you about that [ __ ]
I'm here to to get you through your new
mother skin but I'll see you guys next
week sundays at 12 p.m. love you very
much
kiss me longtime tip of the dick in the
shape